deep in the heart of the mountain is
where kazim kazan live keeps his supply
that's because it's cold here freezing
cold even in summer
some products can be stored here for up
to two years without spoiling
here we store sunflower oil canned meat
potato chips
it's practical and much cheaper than a
climate controlled warehouse
even in summer the temperature in this
ice cellar is normally
15 degrees celsius below zero but kazim
can tell that northern siberia is
getting warmer and warmer
even underground things are naturally
kept cold here in the permafrost
now we've covered the cellar up with
sheets to keep out the warmth
this year the ice cellar was one or two
degrees warmer
but that change isn't too bad it's okay
but for how much longer in the village
of batakai
there are many ice sellers like kazims
the village depends on them for its
supplies
overland access is only possible when
the river is frozen
for four months a year it forms the road
in
and out from about january to april we
can use the winter routes to receive
supplies
in the summer kazim's three stores get
weekly deliveries by airplane
from the regional capital yakutsk it's
expensive
but necessary
with temperatures that can drop to minus
50 degrees in winter
life in batakai is dictated by the cold
permafrost still covers the area but
it's starting to thaw
this is the badagaika crater just a few
kilometers from the village
it's the largest permafrost crater in
the world
one kilometer wide and a hundred meters
deep
and it's growing
the crater was originally caused by
deforestation
as the frozen earth was no longer
protected by trees
today it's also exposed to the rising
arctic temperatures
the melting permafrost sets off a
vicious cycle the organic substances in
the eyes decompose as it melts
which releases more greenhouse gases
which in turn
speeds up global warming
crater are things we're seeing
everywhere else just to a lesser extent
the ice under the ground melts then the
ground collapses
it happens everywhere
crater is the perfect example of why we
shouldn't mess around with the
permafrost
but the true severity of the situation
has been slow to hit home
even though the signs are clear
neighboring riyansk is otherwise one of
the coldest places in the world
but this summer temperatures hit 38
degrees
it's never been so hot because most
houses in the yakutia region
rest on stilts in the ice the record
temperatures could widely destabilize
the building foundations
houses here could collapse because of
the melting
they permafrost on supports in the
ground just like all public water
gas and sewage systems
if they start shifting there could be
accidents
global warming will cause a lot of
problems here
the earth is also moving in qasim's ice
cellar
everywhere there are wide cracks like
this one
which then freezes and reinforces the
walls with blocks of ice
he says ice is always shifting and the
cracks have nothing to do with global
warming
and even if they did he says people here
would adapt
we'll manage even without an eye seller
it's not that bad
let's hope everything turns out okay
for kasim in his ice cellar the effects
of climate change
still seem to be a long way off and many
people here still don't know anything
but cold for most months of the year
but that is starting to change
you